Oh brothers only one is back with us to
reveal her new highly anticipated book
club selection only on CBS this morning
from roll please what's your new pick
miss Wynn for my new pick is olive again
by Elizabeth Strout Olive again only you
can do that soundtrack surprise winning
book what is it Oh
short stories focus on the life of us
stubborn and how shall we say what woman
named olive every time you pick the book
up it makes that noise actress Frances
McDormand won an Emmy for playing the
unforgettable character in the acclaimed
HBO series based on the book in olive
again she navigates her second marriage
and complicated relationship with her
son New York Times bestselling author
Elizabeth Strauss joins us at the table
she's also a Pulitzer Prize winner good
morning welcome graduations graduations
all the way around yes I am so happy to
see olive again oh did you how did you
feel about bringing her back I had no
idea that she would show up again and
then when she just showed up in my mind
obviously but she just showed up you
were in Norway on a trip I read I was
just sitting there doing my emails and
all of a sudden I saw her so clearly and
what did you see you look I saw olive
getting out of her car in front of the
marina with a cane and I realized I have
to get this job what did you like about
well what Elizabeth sprouts I think one
of her secret gifts is that she takes
what is the ordinary and makes it
extraordinary she takes ordinary moments
I mean like Jack getting out of the car
and looking down and seeing the ants
things that we all do all the projects
big belly hitting the table
her gift is taking the the simplest of
things and turning them into something
that feels real to us that happens with
all the characters you know a lot of
authors say they write for themselves
where they write for their characters
and you actually say you have an ideal
reader and that's right I I think about
the reader all the time and I years ago
I realized wait a minute if I can make
up characters I can make up a reader so
I do I made up the reader is there one
ideal readers I would you think no it's
it's not it's not either male or female
or anywhere in between but it is a
reader that I have sitting with me that
I am trying to deliver something to away
if you don't get it right and it's
almost like I I think it's almost like
I'm gonna dance with them and I have to
take the lead you know but I think
you're stupid but I think about the
reader all the time I think okay what
does that way when I was doing my show
every day I had a composite viewer it
wasn't one person but there was a
composite viewer that I am always
speaking to you talk about seeing olive
when you were on this trip in Norway
olive came to you you said initially
fully formed fully formed she just
showed up fully formed and many of my
characters do that but uh being olive
really showed up yeah fully formed yeah
well you might think of all of us a
likeable character show stubborn she's
prickly I love her but there but there's
also I was gonna say something very
endearing about her because she's such a
I love her because I was so 100%
authentically herself yes and I think
she always says the things this is why
this is such a wonderful book if you are
a mother or you have a mother yes and I
love this book and she always says the
things that we are always thinking is so
right when the window was a grandkids
she's a nice kid you don't say it all
the things that she thinks and doesn't
remember so and so is put on a couple of
pounds and boy her breast or rather
large
I first became acquainted when I was
literally watching I was watching the
series on a plane and my jaw dropped
because I was like oh my gosh they made
a film about a certain member of my
family
it was the endearingly annoying quality
is what member of the family sleeps in
didn't you say that people come up to
you all the time and say I am Olive
husband's interesting that people come
up in there and they're very happily
tell me that their olives and then but
what's interesting is when husbands come
up and their wives are right there and
they'll say my wife is olive to me yes
sir I hadn't seen it Oprah's Book Club
Oprah Winfrey's the best person in the
world her job I thought this was good
the Apple TV Plus had said Oprah's
without peer she's close to supernatural
and her ability to command a room and
watching her return to a talk show
format at New York's Apple Carnegie
Library is exhilarating so my question
for you is you were doing Tana hössi
coats's book yes at the book club when
they use words like exhilarating was it
exhilarating for you it was exhilarating
because I was fascinated yes it was
exhilarating for me to be in a room with
book lovers and I walked in and say you
are my people because that's my tribe
and so that's why we have at Oprah's
Book Club where people can join in the
conversation and you can download this
on Apple books and just like by the time
we finish this conversation I'm excited
for everybody to know that we'll be
right back all again
[Laughter]